let's go to your voicemails the
voicemail number to call in any time is
two one nine two david p we haven't
heard from the eggman for a while the
Eggman doesn't like what's going on with
Rush Limbaugh's Presidential Medal of
Freedom
take a listen hey guys for years and
years Rush Limbaugh has been a cancer on
America reading lives with information
hatred making really ignorant people
believe people stupid things and vote
for war mongering people and now that he
got cancer you guys kind of seem to
forget all that stuff no we know you act
like oh he was such a big you know
influence on politics he was a horrible
influence object please don't forget
that either come back and karma means
he's dying from cancer which is what he
is okay and he was a drug addict and he
and he hate his drug addicts he hates
himself and I'm good for him and that's
too bad you guys put my pedestal I
highly disagree with your opinion of
that man listen I think the Eggman
misunderstood all we said was this guy
was a big player in radio a force not
for good and I wouldn't wish cancer on
anybody I take no pleasure in him having
cancer I don't gloat about him having
cancer as I said earlier getting the
Presidential Medal of Freedom is
disgusting he shouldn't have gotten it
it devalues the metal it was a public
reality show stunt by Donald Trump I
don't know that we disagree Eggman
it seems possible that maybe you
misunderstood we've got a great bonus
show for you today
unfortunately Donald Trump is getting
some of the best polling news of his
presidency and we're going to talk about
why and what it means Germany also has a
new receipt law and it is leading system
very very interesting maybe unintended
consequences I want to talk about that
Bernie Sanders has also pledged to
legalize cannabis in all 50 states on
day one as president could he do it is
the question we will discuss all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show